yeah and you keep the option to run  to the queen side as well two c6 d5 c6  which is also probably  winning yeah as you said you're gonna  end the game at some point no go king of  five bishop g5  and make it stop  design is the arbiter and he accepts  the resignation by  nice game yet again by magnus carlsen  destroys the save in this match for  third place wins two  zero and yeah i'm not sure if this is a  big  consolation for him for not winning the  event but  it's probably a much nicer feeling to  leave like this with two pretty games  than  just losing the semi-finals no that's  absolutely i mean that's for sure you  have this  good feeling because it's tough when you  have to when you are losing the last  round  of a tournament any any tournament